dhs secretary mayorkas issuing a warning
to the migrants during his trip to del
rio texas
if you come to the united states
illegally you will be returned
your journey will not succeed and you
will be endangering your life and your
family's lives
now 600 additional dhs personnel are
arriving in texas to assist crowds of
migrants camping under that bridge even
as more flood into the southern border
town they're not listening to him
because he's saying it to us not to the
people coming here fox and friends
enterprise reporter is actually live at
the scene right now with a texas rancher
by the name of laura allen good morning
to both of you good morning guys and
just to pick back on what brian just
said they're not listening we talked to
some of those migrants yesterday they
have made it very clear
they're upset because the biden
administration essentially said that
they could come anyway laura allen here
she's a rancher former county judge
let's talk about how texas dps are the
ones securing texans here they are the
ones that are enforcing laws on your
land absolutely um you know this the
governor gave us the ability to have
texas prosecute trespassing on our
property and in our case you know we do
ranch um we own a large piece of
property here just a couple of days ago
we had 23 illegals come through our
property these were mexicans the mexican
citizens
and we actually intervened and had them
taken from border patrol handed over to
dps for prosecution they're being
processed
for criminal trespassing
and so that has enabled a lot of the
landowners here
to have another mechanism while border
patrol is busy here at the the bridge
dealing with what they have to deal with
dps has stepped in and been able to do
something out in the areas that border
patrol's not able to get to and dps has
already cited about a thousand folks
that have been on texas property talk
about
the morale here in the state of texas i
was telling our anchors in new york that
even every democrat in town is upset
with the biden administration for what
they're doing here in texas well i can
tell you in our county alone
we have a democratic county judge we
have a democratic sheriff we have a
democratic mayor
we're 85 percent hispanic we've always
been a blue county our county went red
in the last election
and all of our elected officials i think
at this point are just pretty much fed
up they're fed up they're tired
we've dealt with more than we should
ever have to deal with we've seen more
than we should ever have to see
and
without washington's help
this has been just an insurmountable
obstacle to us
talk about the sheriff had a special
message for the men and women out here
and and the support that they
need
you know absolutely i spoke to our
sheriff joe frank martinez last night
and he asked me to convey a message
specifically to our citizens
but also to everyone in our state and
all of the viewers
with all of the division that we
currently have going on and the scrutiny
of law enforcement
our community has come together and
really supported law enforcement not
only the sheriff's
department
but border patrol texas dps everyone
that's out here and the sheriff asked me
to please share on his behalf because
he's not able
that he is beyond proud of our community
and our citizens and he is very very
very thankful for the support that we've
gotten laura allen thank you so much
guys uh i can't state it enough when the
federal government has let the people of
texas down it has been the texas state
troopers it has been the the sheriffs it
has been the mayors in the local town
that have stepped up to the plate this
is the border this is the rio grande
right behind me right in front of me the
reason why illegals aren't coming across
this border is because right in front of
me there is a army of state troopers
that are guarding what the what the
federal government should be doing guys
i'm going to send it back to you guys in
new york lawrence great reporting down
there thank you very much
it is a national security crisis that is
according to 26 republican governors
led by greg abbott and governor ducey of
arizona they are calling they've written
a letter to the president they want a
meeting with him to discuss what is
going on on the southern border within
the next 15 days because it is at the
breaking point hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now